[Music]
I am awesome
it happens late at night after 10 and
before four it's called patient dumping
wait so y'all just gonna leave this lady
out here with no clothes on
that is not okay
then you all need to call the police
so you all are just going to leave this
lady out here like this
are you in pain
oh
for any society just to drop somebody
off in the middle of the night and
especially with a disability and expect
them to fend for themselves it's really
barbaric
and if a hospital wants to make the most
profit they want to get the most number
of people in the beds so to get somebody
out and get the next person in find a
place dump them off because if your
heart really is to help those in need on
the one hand but on the other hand if
somebody else's heart is profit
how can you reconcile those two
oh
we've had people who have arrived
literally in in scrubs and open-toed
sandals from mental health units
um where they've there's been a sort of
discharge meeting on at sort of 10
o'clock in the morning five o'clock in
the afternoon they're put in a taxi and
sent down to us last year we had a man
who had been
discharged from the local hospital uh
nine days after having open heart
surgery
[Music]
thank you
hi I'm Emily a talent Community manager
at United Health Group here at
UnitedHealth Group we're providing
Health Care to over 90 million people
worldwide
hi I'm Allison and I just became
eligible for Medicare so I signed up for
a Humana Medicare Advantage and
prescription drug plan I'm excited
[Music]
the NHS has been repurposed from a
public service to something for profit
extraction and all the changes we have
seen have just been about liberating up
these potential assets for the corporate
Raiders to take them over
Health Care is a multi-trillion dollar
opportunity if you listen to any of the
lobbyists it is I mean globally if you
look at it
um
it's it's uh it is a it is a huge huge
Market potential market and the NHS
stands out as a as a 120 odd billion
pound opportunity lobbyists normally
Lobby for one or two reasons a threat or
opportunity the NHS is a nice juicy
opportunity
we share in the risk of ill health
together it's a joint project we fund it
together we share that cost fairly
that's the essence of the NHS
what's truly worrying about the way in
which the NHS is moving is that that
whole Essence is being fractured and
undermined by the involvement of the
private sector and by the underfunding
process
things continue unchecked and this
really is a juggernaut which is
accelerating and seems to be in its
final stages then we will end up I think
and we already are in a situation where
there's a two-tier system
you you will never abolish the NHS the
NHS simply becomes eventually ultimately
a third class
um basic service
the biggest Open Secret in Britain is
that the National Health Service the NHS
is under attack
this war on a unique institution is not
new but has entered a dangerous new
stage
in 2019 more of the NHS was sold to
private firms than ever before
the term privatization is seldom used
its reality concealed in corporate spin
in deceitful words like reform and
partnership
of course the NHS may look and feel the
same and it works often brilliantly
but it's changing fast
with hospitals forced to compete and
profit-making companies cutting back on
vital Services
especially to the vulnerable
this film is a tribute to an institution
that gave Freedom From Fear to Millions
the first of its kind in the world
a last Bastion of true public service
it's also a film about democracy
above all it's a warning
this is Michael and Matthew Moncrief who
lost their father Trevor to a heart
attack
page 66 Trevor Moncrief lived in Melton
mowbray in leicestershire
he died after an ambulance from a
private company anvale answered a 999
call to his home
the ambulance pulls up and they've gone
in to the house and seen Matthew
performing some rudimentary First Aid on
my father
um
at which point they've taken out their
machine taking out the defibrillator
um charted up things look like they're
going okay and at the point at which
they try to administer a shock the
defibrillator fails
um causing great consternation amongst
the staff and that they need a new
defibrillator on on site as soon as soon
as possible
that they're unable to get hold of the
people who can dispatch that a text is
sent to a call center they left messages
with the call center and text in the
middle of an emergency absolutely so no
one directly spoke to someone who would
actually be able to dispatch a new
Ambulance with a working defibrillator
the ambulance staff recommend that my
brother calls the fire service to get a
defibrillator on hand because they're
known to keep them on their on their
trucks and the fire service are
dispatched to my father's address
and and they arrive and they do have a
defibrillator but obviously this is all
contributing to the general scene of
chaos this is all valuable time that's
being lost in an extremely critical
period of a heart attack and we're still
yet to hear back from the call center at
this point so
the situation is kind of descended into
a harrowing farce
they have followed confusion about which
hospital to take Mr Moncrief he was
taken first to Grantham and stabilized
then to Lincoln a heart specialist
center a journey of 45 minutes
every subsequent action kind of went
wrong feels as if there was nothing in
place to account for this eventuality
and that from that point onwards we just
entered this kind of cascaresque
nightmare of poor decision after Poor
decision after Poor decision which we're
certain led to his untimely passing
a report by a leading cardiologist
founder Trevor Moncrief most likely
would have lived had he received the
proper emergency care
and what we have here is defibrillators
that have been bought secondhand that
haven't been tested effectively or
properly for many a month because they
haven't purchased the devices with the
manufacturer's guidelines which smacks
of cutting Corners it's smacks of people
trying to to to to cut costs to make
profit and not to provide the best care
for people who are who desperately need
it
in 2018
the NHS in England spent more than 92
million pounds on private ambulances and
taxis for patients
many carried the NHS logo but look
closely
often unknown to the public private
ambulances are frequently sent to
emergencies
in 2019 the Care Quality commission
warned that patients were put at risk by
private ambulances
East Midlands Ambulance Service which
employed anvale apologized to the family
they declined to give an interview
a Freedom of Information search has
since revealed that anvale was still in
service in the East Midlands in 2017
three years after the death of Trevor
Moncrief
Keith salt waited almost a year for a
gallbladder operation he was in constant
pain
in 2013 he was offered the procedure in
a private Hospital Spire Parkway and
solihull
the NHS would pay for it
a feature of privatization is that
thousands of NHS operations are
outsourced to private hospitals many of
which do not have the same facilities as
the NHS
the same expertise and the same
responsibility if something goes wrong
unlike the NHS private hospitals like
Spire Parkway have slick corporate
advertising
when did you find out that something was
wrong when I actually
um came around in intensive care
and
I was standing at the consultant
standing over signers that experience
problems and that was the reason for
why I was where I was what was the
result of this this mistake he nipped
the ball looked with a 75 percent cut in
it and I had one of the worst injuries
of a ball duck that you could have
without a spouse
doing when I when I did
delve into what
these kind of injuries do a lot of
people in in a few years back
um was quite bad and a lot didn't
survive
um Beyond 12 months
um with this kind of injury I'll just
get this right Dr Mercer
The Specialist who
rescued the situation yeah I suppose he
came from the NHS Hospital the keyway
yes yeah the QA Queen Elizabeth
um but yes he's into until later that
you suddenly realize that unlike an NHS
hospital when there is a problem they
haven't got the the backup to call on at
that particular time as you do in an NH
hospital where they've got
um probably several in the same field
that they can
call on at that time
had you known this before would you have
gone over to it I was desperate at that
time to just get it done yet I was in
that much pain do you think the NHS
should send
patients like yourself to private
hospitals
well I thought
I thought it was good at the time I mean
I was quite I must say I was quite
impressed in the fact that going into a
private Hospital
um as a power steer and you saw the
surroundings and why are you impressed
just simply because the the difference
in in what you were getting for even the
rooms the reception areas the the
facilities it was just so impressive for
somebody who only ever went to
an nihs hospital as to what suddenly you
were being given so it looked good it
looked good yeah
didn't end up being good but it looked
good
in 2015 following Keith Salt's operation
the Care Quality commission published
this report on Spire Parkway
four years later Spire parkway's safety
and surgery were rated good but the
hospital still requires Improvement
it as far as Parkway Hospital ever
apologized to you no
did the surgeon who did it did he ever
apologize to you no
and there is Noah in any nation in the
world
communist or capitalists any Health
Service to compare it
the National Health Service was not a
gift from above
it was conceived In The Blood Sweat and
Tears of Ordinary People
who had built the Imperial might and
wealth of Britain
and yet often lived an abject poverty
in the 1920s and 30s Modern Health Care
was a luxury
children died from dickensian diseases
women still died in childbirth
infection ravaged slums without running
water and salutation
Britain's deadly disease was class
the second world war was a political
Awakening for millions of ordinary men
and women
in 1942 a committee chaired by The
Economist William Beveridge warned that
the war was a revolutionary moment
the elite were worried
what would happen when the soldiers came
home
for many britons the war had been fought
not only against fascism but for a New
Jerusalem of decent homes and jobs and
healthy lives
the beverage report proposed a welfare
state and the world's first National
Health Service
Winston Churchill and the conservatives
opposed it
in the 1945 general election campaign
the war hero Churchill was not always
welcomed in the industrial Heartland can
you hear me
[Applause]
when we are on
what is our policy I can only tell you
that an enormous Mass
I work
[Applause]
made substantial advances in the human
heart and the human head will have to be
made before we can to adopt the full
glorious utopians which the Socialists
will gatherers placed before it
the utopian ball gatherers would soon
have their say at The Ballot Box
representing the majority of britons
the soldiers paper The Daily Mirror
called for a vote for them meaning the
men and women who had won the war and
the right to a New Freedom said the
mirror of equal opportunities and robust
health
Labor's Landslide victory was a shock
and the Tremors didn't stop there and
became open rebellion in the Far East 50
000 Airmen went on strike in more than
60 Royal Air Force bases the greatest
mass Mutiny in British history
the issue was democracy and the right to
be demobilized and not to be part of an
imperial presence east of sewers
arrested and caught marshaled the strike
leaders were set free after a public
outcry the symbolized of Britain that
was now changing fast
on July the 5th 1948 the most momentous
social change of all was announced by
this leaflet delivered to every
household
this leaflet is coming through your
letterbox one day soon or maybe you have
already had your copy read it carefully
it tells you what the new National
Health Service is and how you can use
what it offers
study the leaflet then keep it by you
you'll need it for reference
[Music]
the NHS was founded in 1948 to give
people Freedom From Fear Freedom From
Fear
of Health Care bills at a time of great
need and distress
and that fundamental principle of
Freedom From Fear on the basis of a
National Health Service providing health
care for all throughout the UK
on the basis of need not ability to pay
and free at the point of delivery
that's been an enormous and immense and
an important achievement I mean my
father was a general practitioner in the
30s he became absolutely convinced that
that system which was effectively a
market in health people had to pay he
hated asking for payment from people he
knew couldn't do it he looked on 1948 as
a day of Freedom when he no longer had
to ask people to pay we had something
principled and almost lovely there was a
a relationship between the doctor and
the patient the one-on-one all-important
relationship nurse and patient would she
is really the essence of Health Care was
one that there was no Market
interference no market exchange creating
an e-force that you were part of
something greater than yourself
um it
actually a collective Act of Genius from
1948 to 58 to 68. I was born in 68 and I
was born in a country with almost the
best infant mortality rate in the world
the best place to be born I was born in
a city which had the first baby
incubators you know there we were at the
very Forefront of Health
but in the 1970s a secret plan to sell
off nationalized industry was drawn up
as Margaret Thatcher prepared to take
power
Nicholas Ridley a close Ally of Thatcher
on the far right advised
a preparation for return to the private
sector by stealth
in the same year the American management
Consultants McKinsey and Company
proposed that NHS hospitals should be
like hotels and charge patients a daily
rate
what is the history of this revision
revisionism of the NHS the real Attack
the real decimation started in the late
80s under Margaret Thatcher and two
advisors Oliver letrian and John Redwood
how did they express that
they produced a document called
Britain's biggest Enterprise and this
set out how to get from a public service
to an insurance-based system
they knew that whatever they did to the
NHS if they took it away from a public
service there would be a huge backlash
so key to the plan was to do it very
surreptitiously and covertly and over a
long period of time
but it was the new labor government of
Tony Blair that accelerated the sell-off
Blair used an accountancy trick called
private Finance initiative or PFI
new hospitals were effectively owned by
the companies that built them under
disastrous pay later terms
the effect of PFI has been to
deliberately burden hospitals with huge
debts and these debts were structured in
such a way that they would become more
onerous over time and what that does it
removes money away from the delivery of
care because PFI
repayments are ring fence so money has
to go to pay the PFI above any other
call on that money
so you end up having
the servicing of the debt in preference
to the providing of care for patients
and we've seen
hospitals closed down neighboring
hospitals which don't have a PFI debt
have been sacrificed
to to bail out hospitals with PFI debts
so if you if you look at the total PFI
debt within the NHS we've borrowed about
11 billion and we're going to be paying
back in excess of 80 billion over 30 to
40 years
and much of this was secret wasn't it
the way the way the way PFI was
introduced it was never explained in a
way that the public could understand
what a con what a fraud this was at one
point though the the labor government at
one point was looking at actually I
think it was about a third of the NHS
assets were going to be effectively
privatized in this way and handed over
to PFI and with these deals accountable
publicly accountable they were
profoundly secretive I mean you couldn't
get any access to what was going on at
all they were all behind closed doors
it's an enormous
polling public Scandal 124 hospitals and
more are now built design built and
operated
using
private finance and remembers
accompanied
by one of the biggest Hospital closure
programs and land disposal programs
in the late 1990s Labor's Health
secretary Alan Melbourne declared his
undying love for the NHS
this is a once in a lifetime opportunity
for the NHS to redesign its services
around its patients we've got more money
going in and that will allow us now to
get the basics rights to get more nurses
more doctors more beds in the system but
if we're going to get the best from the
money and we're going to get the best
for the patient then there has to be
some big changes
what the changes concealed was the
beginning of a sell-off
the Blair government pushed through
Parliament a series of bills that opened
the door to private business and PFI
having overseen the changes to the NHS
Alan Milburn left the government
and later joined the board of
Bridgepoint capital a private Equity
company
welcome to care UK
UK in 2010 Bridgepoint bought kuk one of
the biggest healthcare companies
contracted to the NHS which balances May
's Metro services
this is Simon Stevens Tony Blair's
Health advisor in 2004 Stephen stepped
into the revolving door and was hired by
the American Health industry giant
United Health
will want to
because
hold integrity at such a high level
Integrity isn't hard it's living our
beliefs is being ethical it's being
honest
honesty Integrity may be but United
Health has another reputation its former
Chief Executive William McGuire known as
dollar bill was forced to give back 620
million dollars in the biggest share
scandal in corporate history
after 10 years with United Health Simon
Stevens was brought back by the
coalition government as head of the
National Health Service in England
under the coalition government the
budget of the NHS was cut from an
average annual increase of four percent
to one percent
thousands of doctors and nurses have
left the NHS which now has one of the
lowest bed capacities in Europe
[Music]
in the NHS today one American company
stands out McKinsey the management
Consultants with a worldwide reputation
for helping governments reform Public
Services
if you look at the documents that I've
got from around 2010-11 so this is when
they really ramp up the privatization
the reforms of the NHS
um and you look at mckinsey's
involvement there they are attending
meetings in the management board the
Steering group that sets up these new
structures within the NHS
um this is a McKinsey document it's
about designing the new system and they
have set the agenda here this is a great
document this is um them discussing the
new organizational design so you have an
American Healthcare model so they're
looking at Kaiser Permanente there's
lots of glossy pictures of Kaiser
Permanente smiling patients and doctors
I think the management of the NHS have
become dependent on the management
Consultants I think they it seems to be
no longer there's a management uh ever
sit down and actually drop its own plans
they actually bring in somebody else and
at the end of the day all you're getting
is you know the management consultancy
kind of approach in which you know you
come along you know you you ask a
Management Consultant at the time he
borrows your watch tells you the time
charges you a thousand pounds and we've
got that right across the NHS you know
foreign
this is the center of Britain's
democracy Westminster
unknown to many of us a network of
pressure groups lobbyists and right-wing
propaganders have their offices in the
streets the Border Parliament
their target is the National Health
Service
and cave and I are taking a tour
okay and this
humble the bow just ran from Parliament
is the Institute of economic Affairs
tell me about them the iea is an incred
relatively effective propaganda machine
you look at the size of it it's not a
big massive advertising company or
lobbying agency it's a small
organization but the relationship it has
with the media is incredibly tight so it
manages to get its messages into the
Tableau press it's all over the internet
but particularly the BBC we do know from
other sources that it has taken money
from the tobacco companies so for
somebody like Philip Morris the huge
tobacco giant they describe the iea as
particularly useful in getting its
messages out into the public domain the
NHS represents everything that the iaea
stands against so it is a public
institution but right now it has some
friends in very high places
okay we're now in tufton street it's
worth noting that tufton street is kind
of like this epicenter for
these kind of think tanks you've got the
you know low tax Advocates over there
you've got your climate change denials
over there you've got your privatizers
over there you deregulate they're all
here it's brilliant and in the middle of
it you've got the center for policy
studies which this was Margaret
Thatcher's
um Think Tank
so these are the offices of another free
market Think Tank business Lobby group
um it's called reform
um and this is one of the sort of a
younger version of the CPS basically and
it was set up specifically to lobby for
privatization and public services so not
just the NHS but education and Justice
and the like the brilliant thing about
reform very clever this they set up a
kind of front front group so it wasn't
enough that they were then saying the
the corporate messages in the Press they
set up another group they set up a thing
called doctors for reform which
brilliantly was led by a GP one who
specialized in Botox but distinguished
Specialists exactly and he can reach
parts of the media that a think tank
can't it was all around the honey pot
aren't they they're all they're all
closed to power because just down the
road there is the Department of Health
yeah I mean we are
imagine the corporate interest lined up
they are literally behind the Department
of Health it's very very handy
okay here we are in bressington place
just off Victoria Street Portland house
what's in there this is is the Office of
the trade body for all the companies all
the other companies that are looking to
get their hands on NHS money so all the
big outsources you've got in their care
UK biggest NHS contractor there is at
the moment you've got virgin they picked
up two billion pounds worth of NHS
contracts in the last five years you've
got Bupa in there hundreds of million
pounds of NHS work and there's the arm
of uh the biggest U.S health insurer
which is called United Health uh their
Tech arm Optum is a member of this
organization as well it's called the NHS
Partners Network and it paints itself as
kind of part of the NHS family they are
investing in
um influencing the government it's an
investment they make a tactical
investment because it delivers a return
I spoke to a leading lobbyist Andrew
holdenby
the Health Service is a public service
why should it be privatized I think the
Health Service is a lot more of a public
private mix than people may sometimes
think and and actually was right back at
the beginning so uh you know GPS
um a very very crucial part of the
Health Service have always been
independent uh contractors in effect
they they had their contracts with the
NHS but in many ways the main thing I I
have to say is is that uh you know the
Health Service is is this mix it's this
mix of public financing and a lot of
private delivery one way or other that
has built the Health Service we have
today with its strengths and weaknesses
and and I I think I really strongly
think that it should continue to be that
mix going forward but reformers had
advocated for example the introduction
of payment
in the Health Service I think you called
it a membership charge and the people
staying overnight in NHS hospitals
should pay
a hotel charge the idea of a sort of
membership fee was put forward by uh
Norman Warner who is a labor up here
well he's he was trying to answer the
question in a pamphlet for us
um how do we uh get citizens of of this
country to take their health more
seriously so he suggested just as an
idea at 10 pounds a month uh if you like
membership fee which is you know not not
not a huge amount
um but it would be enough to sort of
give give people if you like a sort of
personal stake in in thinking about
their own health care it's certainly if
we think of something like technology
which will be absolutely core it's
already always has been cool but you
know you're going going forward it's
very exciting to think what new
technology can do to deliver Healthcare
that you know a present can only really
be done in partnership with the private
sector the new I.T system in the Health
Service was installed by private
companies and was a total catastrophe
well uh a yes oh I think there may be uh
one minor thing that came out of it so
we can say nearly a total catastrophe
all this wheeling and dealing behind
closed doors fed into the 2012 Health
and Social Care Act which promoted
privatization and changed the NHS as
never before
it's a very large act it's over 450
pages long
and it's really the act that enables
both the dismantling of the old system
that was in place from 1948
and a switch to a newer system which is
much more modeled on the U.S Healthcare
System
s of the US see people watching this
will be shocked to hear that their
Health Service
has been and is being dismantled
one of the founding duties on the
secretary's editors in 1948
was the duty to secure and provide
Health Services throughout England for
everybody
and that's the duty that has been
abolished that duty to provide has gone
the secretary of state has a much weaker
duty to promote a Comprehensive Health
Care
but the duty to provide services in
accordance with the ACT has has gotten
and as well as that
there is now a requirement
to contract a duty to arrange Services
instead
which is really legalese for Contracting
and the way in which our government and
NHS England is choosing to interpret it
as commercial Contracting this uh
external Market created by the
conservative and liberals and the Health
and Social Care Act
was a monstrous piece of legislation it
was also a grotesque a grotesque lie on
the British public both the conservative
party and the liberal party went out of
their way in the election to say that
they were not going to have another
top-down
Health Service and they produced the
biggest and the most revolutionary
change in the National Health Service
throughout its history in the 2012 act
Cameron went on to say it's the biggest
mistake he made and here it is six years
later still creating serious damage to
the Health Service the biggest lie is
that somehow markets and competition
will improve health care we know from
all the evidence that's available that
the more you privatize the system the
more you introduce waste and you
introduce conflicts of interest
so that is a big lie the NHS prior to
the Thatcher's reforms the
administrative costs were estimated to
be less than five percent
but we know now best estimates are that
the cost of the market bureaucracy is
running in the order of 20 percent
so that is 15
diverted away from the delivery of care
the beauty of the NHS came from its
Simplicity and you had money coming from
the treasury to health authorities and
this was divided out between the
hospitals and the GPS there was no need
for this Army of intermediaries we now
have the NHS crisis which is no longer
winter crisis it's an all year round
crisis and that's how privatization is
Manifest but it's very convenient
because it looks like it's the NHS that
doesn't work it looks like it's the
principle of of publicly funded uh
provided and owned Healthcare which
doesn't work
um what people can't see is everything
we've discussed behind the scenes that
it doesn't work because tens of billions
are being siphoned off to running a
market system to
PFI debt to Outsourcing profits to
management Consultants
so two and a half thousand years ago
this woman was walking on the streets of
Babylon
and she sees a frog and the Frog says
lady please pick me up and give me a
kiss I will turn into the most beautiful
handsome
Prince you've ever seen this is Ali
Passa a former Goldman Sachs Trader and
super salesman who claims he is starting
a world revolution in healthcare we're
about to change everything about her
it's going to become completely
democratized maybe not in the next two
five years but certainly next 10 years
is going to become accessible it's going
to be affordable it's going to be
everywhere right Ali Passa became a
national figure in Britain when his
company's Circle Health won a contract
to run hinching Brook Hospital in
Cambridge here from 2012.
it was an historic moment for the NHS
the first NHS hospital to be effectively
sold off
we were classed as a failing hospitals
so we were informed that this uh this
great businessman was coming in
yes and I must admit when I first met
him I thought what a charismatic
inspiring man we have here
you know that's how he came across and
he said so you have my expertise and I
am going to take this hospital to Great
Heights you are going to be the best
hospital in the UK
dream The Impossible that's what he kept
saying as you kept saying dream the
Empire extremely impossible yes okay yes
we had a meeting where Vince cabled then
business secretary attended and he was
obviously very very friendly with alipar
so they came up together and
um Mr cable came and he sat opposite me
and he was talking very very
business-like and he said to me do not
have any doubts about Mr pass's ability
he will he will make this Hospital fly
as a business it will Thrive as a
business
it was all this business business
and I looked at him and I said you know
I don't mean to be rude or anything but
this is a hospital it's the NHS I don't
see it as a business
and what reaction did you he said
um yes it is my dear it is a business
we asked Vince cable for a response he
says he has no recollection of the
conversation
the selling of hinching Brook Hospital
is a story of propaganda
this is how the BBC's news night
reported the exciting prospect of
Britain's first privatized NHS Hospital
time in the UK a district General
Hospital was given over to a private
sector organization to manage six months
on from the start of that experiment
Newsnight has been given exclusive
access to hinchenbrook to find out
what's changed
so in one of our Awards in here we're
getting a hundred percent satisfaction
of our patients there is still a way to
go nevertheless at hinchenbrook they're
celebrating the sixth month Milestone
with cupcakes my job we're feeling that
now we're satisfied with looking after
every single one of our patients these
partner meetings are a big part of the
turnaround strategy they're called
partner meetings because the staff now
own 49 of the company that's part of the
plan reigniting and then harnessing
their creative enthusiasm our response
to that was that every person that
worked at that hospital and the local
community already had a stake in that
hospital
they didn't need to become shareholders
in some fantasy scheme and to be honest
I didn't want to be a part of that that
didn't sit right with me and I actually
said that I said I don't want to have
shares I said this is the NHS
just want to do my job
it was a 10-year contract they promised
absolutely astonishing levels of savings
it was it was absolutely incredible it
was some yes it was something in regions
of 30 300 million over 10 years they
sold this idea they were going to get
all the staff working in the new
Corporate Way and so they gave them all
new uniforms so they no longer had NHS
uniforms they were Circle hinching
uniforms they decided that as lead
nurses we would then on top of our jobs
we would meet daily and go around all of
the wards our own Wards and look very
carefully you know
it would take an hour or so of our
working life to look into the patients
to see if we could actually get them out
quicker and and we used to have to do
that and have and have our results back
for Circle by one o'clock every day as
to how many patients we could move out
so so that we could accommodate the
planned Admissions and the Planned
admissions are the ones that bring the
money in
and the sad thing was as lead nurses we
were we were all put up against each
other so there were six of us and we all
used to work really well before Circle
but because of the nature of it
um we it became very competitive
you know in the performance meetings and
in the operational meetings it was a
competition
and we therefore that cohesiveness
didn't exist anymore so if you still had
patience blocking beds as they said yeah
you would be
failing in this competitive situation
yes yes and I was always a failure I was
always told that you know so it gets to
you and you're being told that
but before 2012 was over
Ali Passa had stepped down
taking a contractual payment of more
than half a million pounds
in 2015 a Care Quality Commission report
revealed that the safety of patients at
hinging Brook including children was at
risk
Circle disputed the report
and says that won a national award for
patient care
the Care Quality commission were brought
in and there was a damning report
produced so bad in fact that they put
the hospital for the first time that
they'd had to do this in special
measures Circle withdrew from the
contract
a dramatic failure in terms of the
privatization project
in 2015 Circle abandoned hinching Brook
which returned to NHS control
when they withdrew three years into a
10-year contract
the NHS was left to pick up not only the
financial damage but the damage it
caused to the local community and to the
staff who had had to work through these
three years of
incompetence one day I came into work as
usual and um my brain had just switched
off my bleep kept going off and I
couldn't remember how to recall my bleep
it was if my brain had gone
couldn't function
oh
so yeah
okay it's okay
it's
a very painful memory
loved
so it was really sad because
I'd worked there so long
how long 24 years
and um
I lost my extended family yeah
the patients and the doctors and
it was a part of my life and it was just
gone
hinching Brook and the circle debacle
should be
in stone given to any Secretary of State
for health in terms of what could go
wrong did go wrong privateers have no
place in the NHS they are there to make
a profit and you know patient care and
health is not about making a profit well
doing that I asked Ali Passa for an
interview but his spokesman declined
here is Ali Passa again promoting what
he called his next project a company
called Babylon health and its app GP at
hand this gives you a doctor on your
smartphone
or a robot
this is the conservative Health
secretary Matt Hancock
who believes technology offers a new
Utopia for the NHS
he's one of babylon's biggest fans
Secretary of State for health Matt
Hancock is very keen on this well I
suppose he is but I mean you know he he
I I don't have much confidence this
guy's ability is Judgment I mean he just
you know he he also appeared in that
crazy advertorial didn't it I mean
that's the other thing you know a big
question about what is his links with
this company he's prepared to appear an
evening standard double spread paid for
by GP and hunt paid for by Babylon I
mean that is just questionable I would
say I need to give personal endorsement
to one particular piece of software I
think if you're looking at the cost of
the NHS and somebody comes along and
says I've got a bit of Technology here
that can replace an awful lot of
expensive clinicians and do their job
just as well or better
particularly if you've already biased
towards Tech you might be uncritically
enthusiastic which I think Matt Hancock
has been so in its long-term plan for
the NHS the government wants to replace
thousands of GPS with consultations by
video and app and robot
this young woman let's call her Illy
isn't feeling well but she doesn't go to
the doctor's office he comes to her via
an app called Babylon health
hello
hello there this is Dr butt from Babylon
thanks very much for choosing us for
your consultation today how can I help
the last day Ellie explains that her
eyes itch
why do you think so many of your
colleagues in the medical profession
have expressed quite serious doubts
about Babylon
so I think those doubts will be very
quickly dispelled by some of the recent
reports that have been published so you
may have seen that there was a report
published by the regulator the Care
Quality commission who inspected our
services and found them to be good
there's also been a report published
yesterday this is an NHS England
commissioned report an independent
evaluation that has shown overwhelmingly
that patients and GPS are really
satisfied with these Services I mean
they've been quite some claims the claim
that your chatbot
achieved a higher score in a medical
exam than human doctors I mean that
wasn't true was it so it was true for
the test that we um did so test itself
was extraordinary according to doctors
working for you I think at the time
answered only something like 15 or 50
questions and yet Babylon claimed as a
result of that that the the chatbot had
intelligence equivalence with human
doctors what we found which was really
interesting is actually there's a huge
amount of variation in actual human
doctor performance so when it comes to
accuracy and and that ranged from as low
as 64 percent right up to 94 with an
average of 80 percent and and then when
we did the same testing with our AI
products
um we were able to show that the AI
performed at about 80 percent
you you've said that the majority
of the medical profession are and I
think the word you use was scans
at babylon's uh virtual doctor
what's wrong with it
I think it
the bottom line is it's a completely
mistaken idea so it it it's based on the
idea that you can reduce
people's health problems down to
perhaps some very simple sort of yes no
questions
predictably churn those through a
machine and come up with the right
answer every time and I think there are
two big issues with that number one it
doesn't work a lot of the time for
anything that's more than very
straightforward
and so when I'm Consulting with patients
um
they may come with the same kind of
symptom
and what I try and do is I try and
understand what it is that's worrying
them and what I need to do to be able to
address their particular concerns so
it's less about
the symptom and more about the person
who's got it
I mean the advertising standards has
picked you up on a number of things
described as misleading one of them was
it was a hundred percent safe or 100 the
best in the world
so I think sometimes things are taken
out of context and that example that you
cite of 100 safe is actually accurate
but it's a hundred percent safe in the
test that we performed now that doesn't
of course mean is there anything a
hundred percent well so that's that's
that's a good point
um but you know and that's why it's very
important that that's why I'm saying you
know that it's all about the detail so
actually in the particular test the
results showed it was 100 safe but that
of course doesn't mean it's 100 safe all
of the time and as as you rightfully
point out can anything be 100 safe I
mean medicine is a science but it's an
art it's a Humanity
um and machines have no
emotional intelligence they cannot
understand people they can't understand
metaphor
they can't um
you know probably the majority of what
my patients communicate to me they
communicate not in words but in what
they do with their body what they don't
say
how they choose to answer my question
and I'm constantly understanding them
through communication that's nothing to
do with words
and again a machine cannot understand
human Communication in that way what we
say in words is actually in a very small
part the minority of what we're actually
trying to say I mean Babylon is a
progeny of circle health
Circle health
has
a rather notorious reputation
and I don't need to go over the details
but it took over hinching Brook hospital
and you talked about the Care Quality
commission giving you a good report well
it gave it
pinching broke after Circle had been
there its worst report of course I can't
really speak on behalf of circle not
having had anything to do with that
organization what I do know
um is you know our founder Dr tally pass
as you as you mentioned
um actually you know did some really
amazing transformative things in circle
and took the hospital you mentioned
Hitchin Brook
um from being a failing hospital to
actually being a highly performing
hospital now no that's excuse me but
things talking about us it didn't become
highly performing and I mean I can't
obviously specifically comment on Circle
but what I can comment on with great
confidence is
um The
Babylon as an organization and uh
actually you know I I can't commend Dr
pass enough for his leadership you know
if you think about the success of uh
Babylon and everything that we've
managed to achieve to transform patient
care here in the UK and and and Beyond
you have words and you have actions
um
and the actions are
taking us further and further towards an
American model the words keep spouting
up the rhetoric
um but the actions are taking us further
away from that public good
towards the kind of American model so
the actions of what tell us what's going
on
[Music]
780 and 105.9 FM and cbschicago.com
WBBM news time 10 53 the news watch
continues listing Chicago several times
Chicago is one of America's wealthiest
cities
article 25 of the universal Declaration
of Human Rights says that everyone has
the right to a standard of living
adequate for the health and well-being
of a family including food clothing
housing and Medical Care
in the United States that right has yet
to be granted
instead a group of health insurance
companies dominate the health care
industry and often decide who shall live
or die
as many as 87 million Americans cannot
afford health insurance or their
insurance is made virtually worthless by
excess charges known as deductibles
at least 20 000 Americans die every year
because they can't get treatment
and this is the system that inspires
so-called reform of the NHS
late at night after 10 and before four
it's called patient dumping this woman
says it happened to her dumped at a
homeless shelter buy a nursing home
alone had you ever heard of patient
dumping before never she says two men in
a white van drove her here to the
Pacific Garden Mission and dumped her
right here at the missions front gate it
was the middle of the night she was in a
wheelchair and she didn't have her
medication
for any society just to drop somebody
off especially with a disability and
expect them to fend for themselves it's
really barbaric and when we saw these
things happening we were we were
appalled at that practice
in the United States The Dumping of
patients is so common that this Hospital
patient was caught on CCTV being dumped
at a refuge
people just want to get rid of the
person and at whatever cost find some
place where somebody can go to and just
dump them and get out of there let's
move on to the next person
and if a hospital wants to make the most
profit they want to get the most number
of people in the beds so to get somebody
out and get the next person in find a
place for a person to go to and if you
can't dump them off because they know
that an organization like ours you know
we wouldn't leave them out there so
they're really trusting the Goodwill of
the organization
[Music]
all right
on the other side of Chicago in what is
known as Skid Row is Franciscan house a
former broom factory that's another
refuge for The Unwanted sick dumped by
hospitals
right now let me see we're walking they
do their best here but it feels like a
warehouse for expendable people
when this is full how many does it uh
this this time here is 148. right all
right
what happens to people who have no
health insurance or maybe have health
insurance but it's not adequate so it's
not like the hospital calls us and says
you know this person's coming up and
this is the this these are the issues
all right no their driver is going to
come by the front door and is ready to
just drop them off right there some of
them have possibly had some surgery some
of them might be psychiatric patients
yeah
sometimes we have to call an ambulance
to have them readmitted to a hospital
because they're they're just not well
enough to navigate the place on their
own
but sometimes we're nowhere near the
door and the person gets dropped off
and so that's very quick and it doesn't
take much to open the door and let
somebody out
foreign
Potter was the chief public relations
executive of Cigna a giant health
insurance company
his job was to spin the company's
propaganda often as he describes with
deadly effect
you were the spokesman the public voice
for a health insurance industry whose
routine practices and I quote you amount
to a death sentence for thousands of
Americans every year yeah that's a
that's an extraordinary statement
it's not extraordinary when you look at
the reality of our Health Care system
that happens all the time every day
decisions were made by insurance company
employees
as to whether or not you will get some
life-saving care there was one case in
particular involved it involved a 17
year old girl in Los Angeles who needed
a liver transplant and her doctors at
UCLA Medical Center uh said they felt it
the chances were significantly good that
she would come through the surgery and
and live many years just remind me of
her name her name is nataline sarkeesian
and there was a medical doctor at Cigna
2500 miles away in Pittsburgh who looked
at the request for prior authorization
which is again a term that is is
prevalent in our system doctors have to
ask insurance companies in advance for
permission to proceed with a procedure
or at least to get coverage for it or
some assurance that they'll be paid for
so that that was what happened the
doctors who attended and were going to
be doing the surgery ask this Cigna and
a medical director said he didn't think
it was medically appropriate for
nataline what does that mean medically
appropriate well even though the policy
covered transplants in his subjective
opinion he said he did not think that
her doctors were correct he had never
seen Natalie and he had never examined
her keep in mind that a perfect match
had been found and the liver the
transplant had been scheduled and the
family came into the hospital on the
morning that the transplant was to have
been done thinking that it would be done
but instead one of the doctors took the
family aside took the parents aside and
said we're sorry but we've not gotten
clearance from Cigna so the family
decided they would try to make a big
media case out of this so what happened
it became very clear to the company that
this was not a media story that was just
going to go away quietly as I was often
able to make them go away
they within an hour or so convened they
being the CEO and the the uh the
president of our Health Care Division
the chief medical officer and a few
others uh on a conference call decided
Well maybe in this case we can make an
exception she was getting sicker by the
day her other organs began to begin to
shut down
and she she died about five hours after
Cigna said it would pay for the for the
transplant and I just said I am in the
wrong line of work I can't keep doing
this my job was to help perpetuate a
very very unfair expensive and
dysfunctional system
what kind of wealth did that company
have at its disposal with there are a
lot of Executives close to the CEO level
who make millions of dollars a year
business billions of dollars flow
through these companies they uh make
billions of dollars in profits off of
that Revenue uh partly to reward
shareholders or largely to reward
shareholders but a lot of the money is
skimmed off or made available to conduct
PR campaigns and lobbying campaigns
in 1996 Dr Linda Pino who worked for the
insurance giant Humana appeared before a
congressional committee with this
remarkable confession
I am here primarily today to make a
public confession in the spring of 1987
as a physician I denied a man a
necessary operation that would have
saved his life and thus cost his death
no person and no group has held me
accountable for this because in fact
what I did was I saved a company a half
a million dollars for this
and furthermore this particular act
secured my reputation as a good medical
director
and it ensured my continued advancement
in the health care field
I went from making a few hundred dollars
a week as a medical reviewer to an
escalating six-figure income as a
physician executive
in all my work I had one primary Duty
and that was to use my medical expertise
for the financial benefit of the
organization for which I worked this was
one of those cases where the request
came in it was just a little piece of
paper on my inbox I just happened to
pick it up next and and it just happened
to come to me and they had called from a
hospital in California a patient from
Nevada had been on a transplant list
heart transplant heart transplant they
had a heart a heart became available a
match yeah and the surgeon was ready to
operate
so I called and I thought this is just a
formality because there's nobody would
do a medically unnecessary heart
transplant you couldn't get through the
transplant process
so I talked to him he explained the
situation they had a heart available
they called him they got him you know to
this Hospital
so I approved it so stamp my little
approve on it and then just everything
went to hell because it was a half a
million dollar transplant so then all
these people start rushing in we got to
figure out a way to deny it we can't pay
for it you've got to call the doctor
back
I'm a physician I know what the
consequences are going to be to this man
who doesn't get his heart
you know he's going to continue to
deteriorate
in his congestive heart failure could
last two days two years but he's he's
been consigned to cardiac hell I mean he
you know he's going to slowly
deteriorate and whether he died two days
later or two years later
you know I participated in consigning
this man to death I mean I signed his
death warrant
I would try to do the best thing I could
do as a physician but I was always
coming up against this huge machine it
was just grinding away to keep patients
from getting what they needed because
that costs money I mean the whole
purpose was to make money
that's the risk for all these other
attempts at privatizing portions of
something like the NHS is when you you
you begin to hand over the benefits the
funds to these private companies to
manage
I mean their goal is going to be to make
money not to provide better care or more
care or appropriate care
this is the town of Wise Virginia
in the Mountain Country of Appalachia
where some of the poorest Americans live
the coal mines once gave people here a
precarious life
today many are unemployed
and unwell
every summer an extraordinary event
comes to wise offering free health care
of a Kind unknown in the United States
this is remote Area Medical known as RAM
It's a Wonderful community that comes
together and actually looks out for each
other they come in we greet them in the
morning starting at five six o'clock in
the morning to come through and we
register and we don't ask them
identifying questions yeah we don't care
if they have insurance we don't care
their income demographics we just ask
them where does it hurt and how can we
help you
Ram is like a pop-up wartime field
Hospital run entirely by volunteers and
set up in an agricultural showground
it's as if the NHS has come to town
people wait for days for the clinics to
open sleeping in their cars
most of them have no other hope of
Medical Care
you're going to stay in the car tonight
yeah so what if what who you're seeing
tomorrow dinner tomorrow you've got some
urgent problems I I actually two week
ago and he's got a feeling she's just
got a cleaning because the school does
free stuff for the Middle School are
they asleep in there
out so
you're safe it is peaceful isn't it
we're supposed to meet up with the
plastic surgeon that did her removal of
her little bump on her head last year
and so he could see a follow-up of what
it looks like this year so he could see
how it turned out so
okay what would that have cost you uh
probably several thousand especially to
get somebody like him because he's
actually a really well known plastic
surgeon from Charlotte so to get him
would probably several thousand dollars
several thousand dollars yes
but it's here you get it for free
my sisters actually utilizing this
because she has no health insurance and
she's a veteran still fighting to get
benefits for that
and so we brought her here to get dental
work because she can't afford health
insurance I can't tell you how happy I
am to be here right now and because I
have some abscessed teeth that I've been
dealing with for the last couple years
and so you're going to have your teeth
hooked up and I have Crohn's disease I
have Crohn's I have a lot of medical
issues too and I haven't been I've been
off my medication because I can't afford
it
what does your medication cost
see the last time I had it was about six
years ago and just for two bottles they
were 490 something dollars a piece oh
and that would how long was that last
week that would last me a month
and that's only part of my meds my
cholesterol is high
I'm a million five about a million five
hundred thousand dollars in debt for for
metal for medical bills but I've been
sued my credit is destroyed from medical
bills
right and so I can't even buy I couldn't
even buy one room my credit is so bad
and I've been sued and I just don't pay
them I can't yeah so yeah this this is
wonderful because Appalachia really
needs these kind of clinics and I didn't
know about them until two years ago
and tonight we're just going to sit in
the car all night and wait
so you're you're sleeping here tonight
yeah
and you've got your ticket for tomorrow
yep tell me why you're here and
glasses and dental and you're getting a
full a full health checkup why do you do
you feel you need that yeah
well diabetes runs rampant in my family
yeah so with this service it gives the
opportunity to stay one step ahead of it
yeah
what are you mostly concerned about neck
back
seven Belgian deers permanent pensioner
in my back and there's nothing they can
do surgical wise to make it better
so I miss them out there helping people
but
you have a lot of pain yeah yeah yeah
and who will you see tomorrow I'll be
seeing the neurosurgeons and those
people in the medical and and over to
Vision to get my
glaucoma on my left eye
what would that cost you to see to get
that kind of treatment outside outside
you're looking at just for the surgical
part about a thousand dollars each visit
somewhere around there so this is like
one of the best things here yeah it was
that they do every year it's only this
free healthcare here that offers you
some kind of solution yeah it helps a
lot not just me my wife
everyone else who that's here that's
camping out tonight
I wish you well for tomorrow but
everything goes y'all too really it's a
plan for you and your wife thank you
it's six a.m and the Sun is just coming
up
everyone has a number
43 44
45. we're offering mammograms pap smears
we're taking chest x-rays we're doing
EKGs inside can I ask you why you're
here I work at a gas station and for me
to get insurance for me and my husband
is over two hundred dollars that's just
for vision and dental I can't afford
that making eight dollars an hour you
just can't I know would you like to see
a free public health service right
throughout the United States I really
would I thought Trump was going to get
it done but I guess that flopped a
little
to have to go out of another state and
get your Health Care Health Services did
you sleep in the car last night no honey
actually
three four in the morning so and it took
us a couple hours drive so and I worked
until 1 30 this morning oh yeah
Ryan was founded in 1985 by the late
Stan Brock a Londoner who believed
passionately in the right of people to
Health Care regardless of their ability
to pay
Stan was the world's expert on three
Health Care
it had to be free
it had to be real care high quality he
didn't want us to tell somebody to go
find a doctor or a dentist
Stan was the guy who could Inspire the
workers
he could Inspire the volunteers
and his words were simple we need you
and that is why you folks are gathered
here today
and in Stan's honor
we will never forget the mission
[Music]
this is one of the most economically
deprived parts of
America the coal industry boomed in
years past and is mostly declined
we have some counties out here that have
no dentist and we have there are lots of
Specialties that we don't have at all
that cities take for granted
nurse practitioner at the health wagon
want me to come because I have chest
pains sometimes and my blood pressure is
like uncontrollably
okay can you describe your chest pain
what kind of appearance sometimes it
hurts like a dog don't hurt I'm armed in
some but this morning it's just been
like sharp twinges do you smoke yes
we're a belt of disease where a belt of
lung disease I'm a pulmonologist so
we're a belt of asthma COPD smoking
we're a belt of lung cancer
where a belt of heart disease stroke
where a belt of obesity and were a belt
of opioid use
tied into mental health issues
so when they come to you what what
typically do they come with they're
short of breath they have a cough they
have exercise limitation they're having
difficulty working and we can do a chest
x-ray on the mobile unit we can do a
breathing test a pulmonary function are
you able to catch disease in time
we did find three lung cancers in one
day here at this event
and so we do find serious disease with
chest x-ray and or other screenings but
the most common thing we find is is of
course the common diseases discovering
high blood pressure discovering diabetes
we discover things that they have no
idea about
a lot of the patients know they don't
feel very well but they don't know why
they're trying to cope trying to exist
diabetes is a disease that people tend
to deny they don't even like the word
diabetes in the mountains they'll say
got a little sugar they won't say the
word diabetes and they're trying to cope
by putting off until tomorrow what they
can't afford today
it's a bit of a lifesaver here isn't it
yeah this is a great program
fantastic
I mean what were the people who live
around here who
who don't have the medical facility
yeah they do without they have no teeth
or partial teeth
they have
no diabetic treatment no high blood
pressure treatment so if they come here
they at least get some medicine
typically what are you dealing with
there what are you treating we've seen
several patients this morning that have
received more than 10 extractions
well the reason these people are here
because they can't afford to go to the
dentist
they can't afford to go to the dentist
or they have insurance that really isn't
working for them some of these people
who work in these small communities
their insurance may only be acceptable
in a regional area go outside that
region the insurance isn't accepted
it just sounds like
chaos it is it's chaos and it's a
vicious cycle and that's why things like
these are so important was quoted
yesterday about these famous quotas
all Healthcare should be free right
I don't deny that I don't disagree with
that and and people are suffering
it doesn't make much sense to me as a
human being
when and how is there going to be free
health care in the United States not in
my lifetime
and our Pharmaceuticals are unbelievably
expensive the highest cost for drugs in
the world
in other countries I can get medicine I
can go to to India and buy medicine for
pennies and give it out to patients but
here when I as a charitable doctor go to
get one asthma inhaler for one patient
that's four hundred dollars for one
month's supply for an asthma patient
when six percent of our population has
asthma it's like an incredible rip-off
thank you
and then they were gone
wrapped up in a few hours
the lesson for us on the other side of
the Atlantic
could not be clearer
could the NHS be reduced to charity that
comes and goes
like this extraordinary event in
Virginia
this is the city of London home to some
of the world's richest money movers
gamblers insurance companies hedge funds
and Banks
it was here and in Wall Street that the
great financial crash of 2008 was caused
by a system of greed mismanagement and
Corruption
most of it rescued by the government
and it was here that the imposition of
an extreme ideology called austerity
was justified
austerity is one of the propaganda
triumphs of the age
because there's no need for austerity
there is a death owed by banks that were
bailed out with our money
we the people don't owe a penny then why
are we paying for it why are the
poorests picking up the bill when some
of the biggest companies in the world
pay little or no tax
why has mass poverty returned to Britain
why are the very premises of civilized
life of which the National Health
Services are Beacon being run down or
put up for sale
why according to one study is there the
greatest rise in mortality in 50 years
the study undertaken by you and your
colleagues gave up some really damning
evidence that thousands of excess deaths
in England Wells were linked to Cuts in
the Health Service in the first seven
weeks of 2018 an additional person died
every seven minutes the only thing that
fits is austerity the cuts customer
Health Service but cuts to social care
as well because as the cuts got deeper
and deeper
people began to die faster
the frail and the elderly first elderly
women who are much more likely to be
living on their own than elderly men and
we first said this over four years ago
and the cuts continued and then life
expectancy itself began to drop
you're talking
about a hundred and twenty thousand
people so far
who have died earlier than they would
otherwise for child and infant mortality
we're ranked we're near natal deaths
we're 19th in Europe
and that's getting worse one thing that
shocks Medics our babies used to have a
three times better chance of not dying
than babies in Portugal in the 60s and
70s Portugal was always put forward as a
terrible place to be born now you're
much more likely to get to your first
birthday if you're born in Portugal than
in the UK
the changes in the Health Service have a
great deal to do with privatization the
change of the character of the Health
Service
has much to do with that and in making
this film we found that it's much more
prevalent certainly than I realized what
what's the impact of that when you think
you're part of something
um which is truly precious people that's
when you work longer hours that you're
not paid for
that's when you spend another minute
with somebody that you wouldn't
otherwise
turn it into a business
where their customers are not patients
and you know the same way that most
people treat
their jobs it's how you get paid but
it's not a vocation and that's very
dangerous of health because you really
want the people looking after your
health
actually care about you not care about
when they're going to be going off shift
on Clapham common in London his glass
door a voluntary organization giving
refuge and food to homeless people
for some of the people here
their predicament Bears a striking
likeness to Patient dumping in the
United States
we're getting a lot of emergency
discharges from local hospitals we're
getting a lot of people who have been
seen by their local mental health units
and been told that although they do have
a mental health problem they don't meet
the threshold for care we've had people
who have arrived literally in in scrubs
and open-toed sandals from mental health
units
um where they've there's been a sort of
discharge meeting on at sort of 10
o'clock in the morning five o'clock in
the afternoon they're put in a taxi and
sent down to us last year we had a man
who had been
discharged from the local hospital uh
nine days after having open heart
surgery we have NHS workers who are
homeless you know it's a testament to
their staggering loyalty that even
though they're they are sleeping rough
they'll get up at seven o'clock in the
morning dust themselves off and go into
work they go and work in the NHS yes
having slept rough having slept rough
yep well we've have care workers we have
Care Health Care assistants people who
get the people who go out and do
personal care for our our aging
relatives are sick individuals
have often times been sleeping on us on
a church floor the night before
this is in Stephen's church in the heart
of London just behind the houses of
Parliament
it's mid-winter
and this is David coombe whose
remarkable organization Street Souls
cares for the victims of austerity
with hot meals clothes glasses that
people can no longer afford
and above all a warm place where people
can feel human again
David just described Street souls and
how it began what I really wanted to do
was a compassionate act involving my two
younger children at the time who I think
were six and eight maybe at the time
and um
I said to them just before Christmas I
said we're not going to buy Christmas
presents this year boys we're going to
buy sleeping bags for the homeless
people we're going to take soup and
sandwiches out to a homeless which of
course didn't go down too well as you
can imagine with young Lads we've got a
big van full up with sandwiches and soup
and literally drove around London and we
did this several times what struck you
at first about the people you met um
that they were just like me one thing
that was very apparent was it's not as
portrayed in the media it's not drunk
everyone's got drunk everyone's not a
drug addict in fact I'd say that was a
minority you know
um totally the opposite of what most
people would probably believe
a lot of these people just had
misfortunate events in their lives
but direct connection between political
decisions and homelessness that's
something you see yeah very much so um
you know in 2010 Westminster city
council tried to pass a bylaw within
Central Westminster to make it illegal
to sleep rough and punishable by I think
it's a tariff five fine fine of 500
pounds you know which is kind of crazy a
homeless person looking at 500 pounds
but also illegal to feed homeless people
what's the direct connection between
austerity and the people that you help
here the lack of Aftercare is something
that I've noticed you know some of the
guys we have here have had some quite
major operations are effectively turfed
back out on the street give me an
example well I've got a fella who
um has had a couple of knee operations
and he's what he calls home is a
Janitor's Closet of seven foot by four
foot in a block of flax you know and
he's that's where he goes that's very
convalesces
um another lovely chap who had I'm not
sure what surgery but major surgery so
he's uh chest look rather like a sort of
a quilt
had to go in a a place he was given five
stories up with no lift immediately
having this operation mode at 140
stitches or whatever yeah um it's just
so wrong yeah yeah it's you know it's in
out you know it's um it's free up the
beds and you know
yeah you know the life expectancy on the
street is 47 years old you know 47 47.
it's heartbreaking because the bar is
set so high now on who you can admit to
hospital because there are so few
hospital beds you know it really is a
case that unless you're threatening to
imminently kill yourself or you're
psychotic to the point of
just incredibly Disturbed as an
individual or a threat to other people
then you're sent home and unless you
what if Homer's not a home what if it's
in the streets well it's just
heartbreaking I mean there's been a lot
of occasions when I've had to send
someone out onto the streets and
you just send them out into the night
and you don't know what's going to
happen to them
John Watts works with David comb as a
volunteer
we are on his regular run to check on
people with nowhere to sleep in near
freezing temperatures
but on the streets
the heaven have and not Society
[Music]
and we don't like to
see
once you have not
David was saying that life expectancy of
people on the streets was 47. yeah
yeah how long has he been there
do you think
months months
excuse me
um part of Street Souls I need to get
one I've just come up to jail
I've got one sleeping bag left oh yeah
all right
you've got one please in oh please I'll
be back in two weeks yep
one you can't use toilet two you can't
get a housing three we're having nervous
breakdown
and
it's not good
what happens to their health
it deteriorates rapidly
they suffer from all sorts of
things
and their mental health suffers
they don't sleep enough they only get a
couple of hours sleep because they're
either moved on or they're nervous about
people and
it's just a downward spiral basically
yeah for those who are not used to being
homeless to speak sleeping on a coal
paper
that must be a shock I think it would be
a shock for anybody anybody in you know
it's bad enough in the summer in this
weather and in these temperatures
yeah
I just find it
unbelievable in the 21st century but
yeah
um
why is this happening in 2019 middle of
London
we've stopped filming when the
frustration of one rough sleeper spills
over
okay
sorry okay sorry
for more than six months we phoned
texted emailed and wrote to government
ministers and officials who run the
National Health Service
the Secretary of State Matt Hancock the
head of NHS England Simon Stevens
the chair of NHS England Lord Pryor
the health Minister Caroline dionage
a former Prime Minister David Cameron
the former Health secretary Alan
Melbourne and many other officials and
politicians
no one responsible for the future of the
NHS was available to be interviewed on
the Urgent issues raised in this film
silence
if you start out with a core a principal
of wanting to care for everybody you
know you you've already started at a
foundation of value
and
I mean we've never really had that here
you know there's never been
you know a Health Care system that
started with ethical values and said
okay Health Care is a right
or you know certain other values we've
never started there and built on it so
that we have a lens by which we can
measure everything that's happening you
do you you have that and if you lose
that then you'll never get it back
we gained the Freedom From Fear uh in
the past uh this enormous sense of
relief from thinking you are no longer
going to be a burden on your family
uh do you know not just having to fear
for yourself and your own pain and
suffering
but the idea that your family would
either have to try and look after you or
find the money for somebody to treat you
and it was one of the most remarkable
and Rapid improvements in living
standards and quantity of life
that fear has come back again because it
was a cool decision to give us an NHS
and we got that
in 1948 with the 1946 Act
it was a political decision to take it
away
in 2012.
it only needs a political decision and
the will of the people and the
politicians because if people have not
lost faith with the NHS they want an NHS
I believe they will reach a Tipping
Point of public awareness
at which time our politicians cannot get
away with the deception any longer if
enough of the general public stand up
and say no more of this
if the profession can unite and realize
the power they have we can stop this
very quickly
the government need to believe in the
NHS not mess about with it
and they need to properly fund it
um
and they need to trust those that are
that are there to get on with their work
and let them get on with their work
people like you
yes
to trust us
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]